e
all right it being 10 o'clock we'll call
the finance committee meeting to order
for February 18th the first thing we
have on our agenda is how post Bill 97
making appropriation to the Department
of Environmental Services for Wastewater
infrastructure projects is there someone
bill all right representative Maguire uh
thank you Mr chairman I move to retain
House Bill uh
97 all right a motion and a second to
retain House Bill 97 further
discussion being none no I mean
this is a very worthwhile project but um
funds are very short so we'll we'll see
if we can squeeze in all of it or some
of it as the process goes forward any
anyone seeing none the clerk will call a
rooll on the motion to retain House Bill
okay representative Maguire
yes representative
Earth
yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes the clerk
votes yes representative Bean
yes representative Kim Bros yes
representative papichi mua yes
representative
Sweeney not here no
s representative Daniels
yes representative
seaworth not here not here not present
not present not present representative
Dy yes representative n vano
he's out introducing a bill he'll be
here later
okay representative
Walmer yes representative leechman yes
representative
Murray yes representative eel yes
tski yes representative hanken Phillips
yes representative
representative priest yes representative
rang yes representative
Ms yes representative
yes there are um one
two three four not present so I guess
it's
okay House Bill 97 will be retained and
we'll try to fit it in the
budget next one next on our list is
House Bill 197 Rel to payments by state
of a portion of retirement system
contributions of political subdivision
employees I'll move to retain for
similar reasons I'll second it motion
and a second did you get
those wire enable
somewhere I get the sheet
here
that's
596 all right about this one here we any
197 was there an amount of money in it
good could you want just tell me who who
are Maguire Maguire and
Abel
okay this is the bill that would pay 7
and a half% of um local um retirement
costs for certain employees and what was
the what was the price tag 28 million 28
year all right we ready
clerk will call a role on the motion to
retain House Bill 197 FN representative
MCU yes representative Earth yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes clerk votes yes
representative Bean yes representative
Kell yes representative papichi Miler
yes representative Sweeney
not
here representative Daniels yes
representative seaworth is still not
here
right representative uh
yes representative n
ABS representative walner yes
representative leean yes representative
Murray yes representative evil yes
representative tulinsky
yes representative hackin Phillips yes
representative
him uh representative priest yes
representative rung yes representative M
yes representative
Kelly yes chair wer
yes that's 21
again okay 21 to zero the bill will be
retained and we'll see if it will fit in
the
budget next on the list is House Bill
FNA directing the state conservation
committee to implement the Conservation
District climate resilience grant
program and making an approach
appropriation
therefore uh representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman I move to
retain I'll second and motion by Maguire
second by able to retain House Bill
246 further
discussion do you remember the size of
the grant that's mentioned in this bill
this is very tiny I think it was 50,000
a year oh for two years all
right might be easier to fit into some
other things come by
yeah if if we had any room which we
don't but anyway go
ahead further comments from committee
members seeing none is the clerk ready
to call the role on the motion to retain
House Bill 246
FNA representative
Maguire yes representative Earth yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes clerk vot shes
representative Bean
yes representative cell yes
representative papichi M
yes swey is not here no representative
Daniels yes seaworth is not here oh we
see him now uh representative seaworth
yes representative Dy yes representative
n vano not here yet here still not here
representative walner yes representative
leechman yes representative Murray yes
representative eel yes representative
tski yes representative hackin Phillips
yes rep is Stringham present no not yet
not yet representative priest yes
representative run yes representative
muns yes representative Kelly yes chair
wer
yes all right does everyone understand
the letters that go on the back of some
of these uh bills obviously FN is a
fiscal note a is an
appropriation so and sometimes you'll
see some with FN and L the L is the
local so it means either the county or
the or the city or town are going to
going to be affected by it um
oh yeah 22 as much as the rest of us um
Mr chair yes the vote on the um on the U
246 was 22 to Z 22 to Z bill will be
retained we'll try to fit it in the
budget next on our agenda is House Bill
519 FNA making an appropriation to the
Department of Health and Human Services
to fund and support the Waypoint Youth
and Young Adult shelter
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I move to
retain House Bill
519 I'd second that who was the second
tki representative
tersi okay any further discussion on
retaining House Bill
519 short comment sir this is an
appropriation of um requesting $500,000
in each of the coming years and um we
want to keep it in the uh budget so that
we can consider it uh as we as we go
through our
process thank you anything
further seeing none clerk will call the
role on House Bill 519
retain representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
Mooney yes representative Edwards yes
clerk vote is representative
Bean yes representative Camrose yes
representative Papa Bishi mu
yes representative Sweeney not hear you
AUD representative Daniels yes
representative
seaworth yes he's here h is here he
voted yes
oh
yes representative deoy yes
representative
Nano not here representative walner yes
representative leechman yes
representative Murray yes representative
eel yes representative tulinsky yes
representative ha
Phillips
yes uh representative Stringham still
not
here representative priest yes
representative rung yes representative
Ms yes representative Kelly yes sh wer
yes
22 22 to nothing House Bill 519 FNA will
be retained by the committee for
inclusion in the budget representative
Maguire is recognized thank you Mr
chairman so this morning we got a piece
of paper from the
LBA that compares um what the governor
has given us in her budget and but with
um numbers that we now have from house
ways and means we have sort of
unofficial numbers from house Ways and
Means as to what we what they think we
will get
in um in funds for General and education
funds Highway funds and so on so so this
piece of paper
Compares um Governor spending and our
Revenue all right um and in
particular and the bottom line of this
is the size of our problem um and that
is for the banum we are short
m948
th000 so this is a huge problem and and
um I I want to point out a couple of Big
Ticket differences between um that are
in and that are not in this particular
budget so first of all the governor for
the current year fiscal year 25 takes
$81 million from the rainy day day fund
that's not in the ways in in in our
figure so so um if we did that that 732
million would be 81 million less the
governor also has um 127 million from uh
slot machines um as that's a new thing
there's a I think there's a related bill
in ways and means that's not in the ways
of means figures so so if we were to
take that that would be another you know
127 million to the good assuming that
happens but what's not in the governor's
budget are some things that we might
consider ourselves committed to and that
is the YDC payments $150 million for the
banum is not in the governor's budget
and the the down payments on the prison
may or may not you know that that we had
considered we were going to spend 40
million a year for 10 years to pay for a
$400 million prison those are not in in
this budget um on that one in particular
I've heard that we may end up borrowing
the money which I think is possibly
appropriate but but in any case the
point is our problem is serious um and
um it's in the range of of 700
million Mr chairman oh sorry all right
represent Edwards and represent thank
you Mr chair and thank you for that
summary representative McGuire I I I I'm
obsessed with keeping track of uh the
the commitment that the counties would
like us to make for the 22.3 million or
25 million depending on what the real
number is so that would that would be an
addition to to the contingencies I think
you just laid
out representative tki thank you Mr
chairman I'm wondering if the document
that um representative Maguire was
reviewing is available did we get it
email to us or um I I think so and and I
can make copies it's it's a little
awkward because one is a legal size and
two are regular size but yes I I'll ask
this came from Mike Kane so I can ask
him to provide it or
yeah uh yes as of now it's only been
provided to uh you and representative
wer the division chairs who were in the
meeting this morning but if it's your
wish to share it with all the members we
can do that yes we'll do
that all right who who was next I guess
representative rang and then
representative ail thank you Mr chair um
would it help the the spot we're in you
know using Mr uh representative
Maguire's figures if there is a I
believe there's a bill that was
introduced to restore the interest in
dividends tax um even if the exemption
was increased to only apply to people
that have more than $100,000 in
dividends and interests would that help
our Revenue picture if that bill was to
pass uh we'll see what that will go to
to ways of means and if ways of means
does something with it then they would
give us a corrected Revenue estimate
it's same thing as if the slot machine
things passes then they may give us a
corrected
Revenue if if they think the U slot
machines will produce as much revenue as
the governor has in her budget so but at
this point probably on Thursday they
will the ways and means way it's
traditionally done they will present a
revenue estimate it will be voted on by
the house so it becomes the law on us
and then it is tabled but if they come
later to add more Revenue then they
would take it off the table and and make
an adjustment
but if that doesn't happen we are bound
by the numbers that we that we presently
have from that from their
preliminary that's that's our bottom
line we can't spend more than that by
the traditions of the house and the
law but I I guess but the restoring the
dividends and interests would be uh
contribute to revenue would it not it
would okay thank you pass y repres
I think I had represent Abel next and
then representative Edwards yeah thank
you thank you Mr chair I mean you'll be
Distributing that I know um
representative Maguire but does the
spending that you have in that uh chart
include the spending that is appearing
in hb2 at this
point yes thank you for the question I
believe that it does with possibly one
exception and that is um the retirement
system for group two change
um I think that's not yet in the this is
effectively a surplus statement and I
think I think that one there's still
there haven't been any discussions with
the retirement system so they're having
trouble figuring out just exactly what's
the right number to to put
in representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair and and for representive rung
and maybe other new people I I think I
think the way Ways and Means uh captures
um their process is in part they say
they only factor in current law so the
proposal that that you're thinking of is
not current law and so therefore ways
and means that would be precluded from
considering it in the estimates that
receive yes there will be many moving
Parts before we're done we have till the
end of March to come to conclusions and
we'll be
working in all our divisions to try to
find places where we can make cuts
and and we'll be looking um with all the
suggestions to spend more money and and
we'll have to try to figure out which
ones we can afford and which ones we
cannot and unless we find places where
we can cut in the rest of the budget
there's not much chance um the governor
took money out of the
the rainy day fund that would be a last
desperate measure if that's the only way
we could balance it but there would be
enough to make up for the huge
difference we've seen so we still you
know at best there's 200 million there
representative Ms uh M Mr chair Could
you um explain um the um the the
interface between the education funding
committee and our committee I mean will
will we be getting
um will they be providing us with
indications of what they believe should
be spent on education funding that we
then roll into the budget how is that
going to work yes we have we have some
of our members from this committee that
are also serving on that committee so
we'll have pretty instant feedback and
uh we'll have to see how that all comes
out um there's less Federal money and
there's fewer students so let see what
what the uh net results are I know this
lot all sorts of people wanting more
money included in the in the education
fund but whether or not it's available
in the revenue that we have remains to
be seen those will be some decisions
that we will all have to make
eventually as they as they bring their
input to us so we'll see what happens
there'll be some some moving Parts there
as well so too early to predict it all
right representative bu yeah just more
specifics so I'm one of the members of
that committee and we have bills in that
committee that essentially touch on on
every aspect of uh education funding
right the the formula the special ed the
you know all kinds of details um swept
and things like that so so whatever
happens with that committee and what
happens on the floor with those
bills most of those bills will come back
to our division 2 and then uh can
incorporated or changed or whatever as a
second committee I think one of the
biggies and this is something we had in
and out for 20 years is the donor towns
and whether the people that get more
money in swept get to keep it all in
that town or whether they turn it into
the state to be redistributed to towns
that didn't have as much money in there
swept so those are uh that's something
that that's come up again we had it for
a few number of years and
then people that were from those towns
fought it every year and finally went
back to no more
redistributing but now that's come up
again and some of those bills increase
swept for most of its uh existence it's
been at a set figure
363 I had most of the numbers I'm not
sure what year that
was
created it's got to be a good 20 years
ago speaking of Education funding we
have to go yes all right you have to go
to that committee all right thank you
all for coming at 1:00 division three
meets uh
today and they have dhhh commissioner
over review Budget Trailer Bill if
available so we're also having
discussions uh on our morning meeting we
also had the um chairman of Public Works
because they have have to produce the
capital budget capital budget is
mainly fix a roof build a
building PVE a parking lot that sort of
thing um those are things that have a
long
life um lately the information
technology pieces have been added in
there and so if if they do them maybe we
don't have them in in the budget we have
we'll see that what happens with when we
look at our budget whether a lot of that
information technology gets put over
onto the capital budget rather than the
regular budgets but almost every um
Department we will look at will have an
IT line some of it just for the
operation of it rather than a new system
the new system if it's got a 5-year life
or more could go into capital budget but
the question I would have for the IT
people normally in the in the regular
economy when you come in and spend a lot
of money on a a new program you save
money in the operation it becomes more
efficient you don't need as many people
you don't need as much time so my
question will be to the
it every time you bring in a new thing
how many jobs are saved how much time is
saved and so on so that's that's one of
the interesting things had to hand up
representative Mari thank you would you
object if div 2 headed over to Ed
funding yes no I have no object yes that
that would might be a good idea you all
adjourned reverse this much I me she's
not going to be too surprised I'm going
to ask about did you look at the DHHS
capital budget it just got two
items one is enormous and
it's investing ining to
developability
system